We have surface-level conversations all
through the day. It's why more people
than ever now feel unfulfilled and no
depth in their life. The biggest problem
of my life is that I cannot initiate
conversation with a not stranger,
anyone. Uh, okay. Because I just feel
that I will not have anything to
communicate or anything to share. I feel
that I just could not carry the
conversation further. Right. So, I just
hold myself back and just shut up. I
just want to be able to start initiating
conversation with the strangers. Yes. To
expand my network.
Thank you for the question. Does anybody
else here have the same fear meeting
strangers?
Okay.
You're not alone.
There's a lot of people here asking the
question. Okay, so So, please know
you're not alone.
One of the one of the main reasons we're
afraid of having conversation with the
others is What are you afraid of? You
tell me. What are you afraid of? So, if
you were to do it, what are you afraid
of? What are you afraid's going to
happen? I'm just afraid that I will not
be able to speak any further. I won't I
I don't have any incidents to exciting
incident to share. Yes. Right. And I
don't want to share anything obviously
bad or anything which which shows, you
know, puts the conversation off. So, too
too scared of speaking, basically.
There's an obsession about getting it
right. I don't want to do it wrong.
That's right. Okay.
>> That's right. So, I don't want to do it
wrong, right? Exactly. Now now now, can
I share with you a quote that I want to
put in my book that my publishers hate,
but I'm putting it in there anyway?
Here it is.
The price you have to pay to become
great at something is you first have to
be a little bit
That's the thing you have to accept.
First thing is you are going to be bad
at it the first time you start. It's
inevitable. That's how we all get
better.
So, what happens when you fear it is you
do less of it, and when you do less of
something, you don't get better.
There's no chance for you to get better.
So, the first thing is I want you to
just adopt the mindset of imperfection.
It's okay. You've got to be a little bit
bad at it, and I want you to do it now.
Now you've told everyone this, when
you're out in the breaks, I want you to
go do it. But, I'll give you a framework
to do it with. Okay? So, if you see a
whole group of people that are having a
really good great conversation, you want
to be a part of that. I want you to just
walk up to that group and now this is a
challenge. Are we all going to keep
Preet accountable to this? No, please
Yeah, we are. No.
No, Preet. No, no, no, no, come back
here, Preet. To the microphone. To the
microphone.
Because we're now going to support you
in this, okay? And then here's the game
we're going to play. Here's the other
fear he mentioned. Again, we got to
listen, active listening, right? What if
I don't have anything interesting to
say? Like there's a fear of one
perfection. There's a second fear of,
but I'm not interesting. So, the second
thing that I'm going to share with you,
this is so simple, but people won't do
it because they go, "Ew, it's gross."
No, you're gross for thinking it's
gross. It's not gross. There's a
wonderful conversational game you can
play with people you meet. It's called
high low buffalo. I love this game. Have
you heard of it before? No.
Unbelievable. High, you share something
that's going great for you. Low,
something that's not going so great for
you. Buffalo, something interesting
about you. Now, the reason I get you to
play this game is because what this
creates is it creates conversational
threads.
So, when you first normally meet
someone, how does conversation go? "Hey,
how are you going?" "Good." "Oh, nice to
meet you." "Okay, cool."
Right.
"So, what do you do?" "Oh, I'm in
accounting." "Oh, exciting."
>> [laughter]
>> Uh what what do what do you do? "Oh, oh,
I I'm I'm in law." "Oh, yeah."
Yep. Uh oh, have you seen the House of
Dragons?
"No, didn't get didn't get into it.
Everyone says I should watch it." "Oh,
okay, that's cool." "Do you watch
Friends?" "No, no."
"Have a good workshop. Take care. Okay,
cool." Always happens like this, right?
So, there's no threads there's no
threads at all. So, when you play high
low buffalo, as awkward as it is, all
play it in the breakouts and you have to
play it. And I want you to report back
to me if you do multiple times. So, do
high low buffalo with me now. You ready?
High, something that's going good for
you in your life. Low, something that's
not going good for you in your life. And
something interesting about you.
Okay, face one of your deepest fears.
Are you ready? No. Uh then then
then I'll give you a moment. I'll go
first. Okay, yeah.
>> Can I go first?
>> Yeah, that'll help.
>> Okay, thank you. Something that's going
really good for me right now is
just 3 days ago we got an email from
Warner Brothers and on the same day
Disney reached out. I'm super excited
about collaborating with these these
businesses. The thing that's not going
so well for me in my life is my son's
been experiencing a bit of bullying at
school. Uh that that's really sucked for
me and I saw we're working through that
as a family. Uh the third thing, uh
something interesting about me is that I
now
am the proud father
of seven chickens.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I
just That's
>> [applause]
>> It's been a lifelong dream. Lifelong
dream to have a chicken coop. So, that's
me. Yeah. Have a go.
It's okay. You'll first have to be a
little bit then you'll get better.
Yeah. There's no right or wrong answer.
High is that I'm doing very well in my
job in spite of not having a good
network. I'm really performing and uh
and
See the most No, no, that's okay. Keep
going. Keep going.
>> Because
because of my past experience, I've been
doing really well in my job. I got vast
experience in finance industry. That's
helping me to
do the best in in what I'm doing.
Beautiful. I love what you did there.
Something he did that that was wonderful
was that when he didn't know what to
say, didn't um didn't uh didn't freak
out, just paused.
Thought of the right thing, then spoke.
You're doing great. And low, something
that's not going great. Low, I think
I've already mentioned. I'm
zero in networking. I'm zero in
initiating conversation. Mhm. And I just
feel something bad is going to happen if
I initiate the conversation. Mhm. Thank
you for sharing that. And And how about
something interesting? Interesting is
in spite of these lows, I just keep
doing what I'm doing best, that is, you
know, guiding people
to um towards getting into their first
homes, towards, you know,
uh helping people
to meet their goals. Beautiful. Yeah.
Okay, that's great. So, you see what
happened here. I gave him three threads.
Okay?
Potential clients, one thread. Bullying,
second thread. Third thread, chickens.
He gave me three threads. Very proud of
how his career's progressing in finance,
thread. Second thread is that there was
the my inability to communicate and
sometimes initiating conversations.
Third thread as well, he's so proud that
he's able to help people get into their
first homes. There's six threads for
conversation now.
Six threads. So, then what happens when
you're in these scenarios with these six
threads,
which one of mine do you want to pull?
I gave you chickens. I gave you Disney.
>> I'll I'll ask the bullying thing because
a lot of a lot of children are suffering
that. How did you overcome or how how
are you helping your son to overcome
that bullying so that he becomes
confident in the groups that he goes
Yes. and that it should not impact his
future, you know.
Yes.
>> confidence, yeah. Thank you for your
question. Okay, so you see, now what's
happening here, and I'm showing you in
the conversational thread world, what
he's doing is now he's asking me a
question that he's genuinely interested
in, but that I'm also genuinely
interested in. We're not talking about
Game of Thrones.
Okay? We're not talking about these
topics. So, now I get to talk about
something that I'm also interested in
and he's keen on hearing. Okay? So,
I I love to share with you. I My son's
on the spectrum. So, my son has autism.
And the thing that I've realized that I
need to do as a father to help him on
his journey is to help educate
the other kids, the school, and the
other parents about autism.
And the things that he's been teased on
is things that they just don't
understand. That's okay. I understand.
We we tend to fear what's different and
we're scared of what's different. So, my
wife and I, we bought a book about a cat
that has autism, and we bought one for
everybody in the school for the kids and
to bring home to their families. And to
to my son's class, I I read that book
out to them.
And said and I explained it as I said,
you know, all of you have a superpower
in this class. You know, Peter, you are
so amazing at soccer, that's your
superpower. Laura, I said, your
superpower is you're an artist. I see
your drawings on the wall. So amazing
what you draw. You know Xander's
superpower? He knows every single animal
in the world.
And he can tell you about their average
weight class, he can tell you about what
they eat. We all have superpowers.
And just by doing that now, I changed
the language of Xander just being
labeled as autistic to him now being,
oh, what's your superpower? What's your
superpower? That's Xander's superpower.
So we it's education.
Because I don't believe people are
innately mean, I think people want to be
useful. They're just they're kids.
They're 8 years old.
So that's the first step that I've
taken. Can I ask you a question, too?
Please. Yes.
How much has it cost you not being able
to communicate well and not initiating
conversation? A lot. A lot.
>> Can you quantify that for me?
Um
very small
friend circle. Yes. I can count on my
fingers. Okay. And of course,
confidence-wise, I've I've lost a lot,
yeah. Because the less you speak, the
less confident you get, I think. Yes.
Yeah. The The whole point of me being
here today Yes. is This is the biggest
fear that I What if I was called on the
stage? I didn't want to.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. This was not what I
what I was hoping, but I think now at
this moment, I really feel glad that I'm
standing right in front of the genius.
Yeah. So
>> [applause]
>> You played that beautifully with me. I
didn't have a surface layer conversation
with you. I had a meaningful
conversation with you. Whereas often,
without people realizing, we have
surface level conversations all through
the day. It's why more people than ever
now feel unfulfilled and no depth in
their life. But it requires courage to
be first It requires courage to
go, hey, do you mind if we play that
weird game that Vincent said to play? I
mean, I don't want to do it, but Vincent
said we got to do it, so can we do it?"
Lean into the conversation, and here's
your opening line when you see a group.
Okay, you have to do this.
You have to go, "Hi, my name's Preet.
You probably remember me from the stage
before."
>> [laughter]
>> "Do you mind if I join the
conversation?"
And and and watch what happens.
And watch what conversations will flow,
and step into the future version of you.
Yeah? Can I give you a hug? Please.
Yeah, you should hug it out after that.
Yeah, well done. Well done. So proud of
you. Well done. Thank you. Well done. So
proud [applause] of you.